hey guys listen i know what's going on
in there you're sucking each other's hot
[ __ ]
i'd like to take this moment to say i
endorse podiums
that's a product i can stand behind
[Music]
no but i will tell you that i one time
worked for otis elevator i don't know if
you know who they are
otis elevators they make elevators it's
a company
and they wanted me to come up with a
slogan i thought i had a great one otis
elevators they never let you down
but
hey let me ask you this did you ever
toss a prostitute off a bridge
don't make he's not dead no no he's 96
he's 96
yeah he's 96 and his [ __ ]
but i mean i've never i don't want to be
tossed in with people that
actually did not crimes but sins or
you know i uh you know i
i barely have a consensual sex
[Laughter]
i am not a big fan of video games
where you cannot kill a prostitute i
like the ones where oh at grand theft
auto yes
wait i have a question so you guys are
are two very funny females
but when you post videos on the internet
sometimes uh
being a female is a little bit different
than if i was to post a video on the
internet what's that like for you too
sometimes uh we've been called certain
things uh
many times you deal with that i think i
think i'm numb to it now we've been
called everything so many times i can't
even
in the beginning anymore oh my god i
can't believe this we should just stop
doing this and then now we just don't
read the comments and keep doing it yeah
i think that's the only thing i think
the last question is are you guys
talking about
barfi man 362. exactly
is that you no that's that [ __ ]
i don't even want to give him attention
but uh
you know listen you know saying those
kind of things about me
talk to him talk to him right now talk
to barf listen barfi man 362.
no you cannot rape my mother with a
knife
now it's official yeah that's the kind
of comment we didn't want to read
anymore
yeah a lot of a lot of sandwich makers
[ __ ] go make me a sandwich
those ones bother me less than the night
oh yeah the ranging ones are worse yeah
you don't want to be right for them
yes i'll gladly rather be raped with
something else
yeah i have an oral fixation my doctor
tells me which is not good
how did he know that i was stuck in his
[ __ ]
yeah i was just thinking you know
because that had that viagra thing out
yeah and the other day
but you know bob dole said came right
out and said he was one of the first
yeah
and you know you don't want to hear
about bob dole's [ __ ] you know
i mean president clinton's [ __ ] bob
dole's [ __ ] what the hell
but mostly an old man like that an old
man
you don't want him to have a super you
know what hard
mean why why because an old man you want
him to be
i got pipe going a newspaper the dog at
his feet there
well that in some corners is considered
pipe
oh but now they're going to have to
create some goddamn pill that makes
women aroused at the same
[ __ ] 70 year old dude with a super
hard cop
it's crazy this is viagra it's insane
and you know it's for impotent people
all right for impotent guys
so get this the i read this the the the
pill can make your [ __ ] hard for four
hours right so now who has before
our hard [ __ ] the impotent guy
the rest of us are [ __ ] me and you
me and you got a regular cox meanwhile
[ __ ] spade is
you know
[Applause]
he brought it all around and then a
vicious rip kick into his best friend's
[Music]
gut
[Music]
you